biggest question I walked away with
after seeing this film King Kong villain
or romantic leading man romantic Lili
man well I'm not sure how romantic he is
I don't think he want King Kong taking
you out on a date definitely leading man
enigmatic mysterious powerful happy no
no no your character Conrad comes in
obviously with a certain set of ideals
and once he encounters this beast they
change tell me a little bit about the
evolution of him
so what I loved about the arc of this
character is that it's it's a journey
from cynicism to enlightenment that he's
so he's British Special Forces SAS the
most highly trained unit in the British
Army they are not to be messed with and
I think he's a man who's seen a lot some
things that are unimaginable horrors
that is difficult for most of us to
fathom and he's a bit lost and it
doesn't really know where to go or how
to adapt to an urban environment or
peacetime so he takes this commission to
go to this undiscovered island in the
South Pacific and through the encounter
with Kong and with the island has a
sense of wonder reawakened within him
yeah it's wonderful to see yeah that
change in him and I think all the
characters went through you know a bit
of a little journey do you personally
ever sort of wish that you could go to
an understanding of Earth Island and
just do your own thing
I don't know how long I'd last if it was
this island you look like you're pretty
good shape
well what the whether or not I'm in I
could I could survive the the I've often
thought like when I watch documentaries
about the Amazon basin or you know those
undiscovered territories on our planet
which are still beautiful and unspoiled
I think you know would I be killed on
the first night or you know or would it
be like well I last a second day like -
yeah but you know there are they still
that you know you see some as you see
footage aerial footage of those
communities in the Amazon that's still
indigenous to that you know it's a
really amazing to be able to survive in
those elements you have some wonderful
scenes with brie Larson yes great
chemistry dear did you give her any
advice on joining the Marvel Universe
no she doesn't need any advice for me
she is an Academy Award winner I did we
are sort of you know we told Sam Jackson
and I told stories about what it's like
on those sets and also just the stamina
required to get to finish those suits
they're long so you were prepared then
to do Kong after having played in in
marble world yeah the difference between
this and Marvel is that that so much of
my work with Marvel is on as on set an
actual build set inside a studio and
there's something about magical about
going to real-world locations you know
we went to Hawaii in Australia and
Vietnam and and the places we went to
I'm so beautiful and so atmospheric and
the fact that all of us were thrown
together that you know that made it
different much I'm assuming much easier
as an actor to respond to a real-life
waterfall than a green-screen yeah yeah
life or even if Kong refuses to show up
for the finished product well you know
he is called he's the star of the show
Tom yes he is the star of the show
yeah